again covered numbers have increased
once again across the uk in the past
week straight to our health
correspondent ashish joshi in the
newsroom so give us the facts and
figures
the upward trend that we've seen over
the last few weeks continues with cases
rising across all four nations i'll give
you a breakdown of exactly what it is in
each of those nations the number of
cases in england
has risen to 1 in 25 that's one in 25
people in england and that's up from 1
in 30 last week
that means now in england we have over
2.1 million people who were infected
with kovid for the previous week and in
wales the figure is one in 20 of tested
positive that is up from 1 in 30 the
previous week northern ireland has seen
cases rise to 1 in 19 people that's up
from 1 in 25 people and in scotland
cases have risen slightly to 1 in 17
that's up from 1 in 18
last week so the upward trend the number
of people who are infected with covid19
during the summer is continuing to rise
and and that will concern especially
the people who are trying to run the
health service at the moment under a
great deal of pressure through the
summer as they are
through the autumn and winter but they
have seasonal pressures and and trying
to clear that elective backlog of the
people waiting for their operations and
treatment that this is going to put more
pressure because everyone who's infected
with kovid who does end up in hospital
and we are seeing hospital admissions
rise and we are seeing more people
attending hospital with kobe that puts
more pressure on the hospital it has to
implement covert infection controls and
also you must remember too that a lot of
these people are infected are key
workers they are people who work in
hospitals they're teachers and that's
why we're seeing so much disruption with
so many employers saying that they have
people are sick at the moment that trend
we've seen over the past few weeks
continuing upwards
all right ashley thank you very much
indeed